[Music]
perception the this season you're
getting to shoot some in in Paris we
shot the season premiere in Paris which
was amazing it's gonna be what a great
thing to get to do I mean my character
it has paranoid schizophrenia so he's in
Paris he's imagining government agents
everywhere and we're super on the street
I mean it was like the Bourne Supremacy
except without any car chases or guns or
any actual espionage right anything that
would be expensed without shoes it's
boring just like you can get postcards
so so and you have scenes with with
mimes
and you and what's interesting you have
a scene with a mime and I know that you
had worked or studied to be a mime at
one point or you had to study I've been
trying to bring mine back to American
television for some time
yeah and I got I finally got to do it
with this episode of reception I studied
it in school we went to theater school
in Canada and we had this famous mime
teacher that's that's a relative term I
don't think I don't know how name is
mine himself he let us know no famous
teacher except he doesn't actually say
it right yeah yeah but we were all in
tights this whole class we're doing
commedia dell'arte one day and this is
one guy who was in my class I won't name
names he's a little guy but not all of
them was little some of them was very
very big and in tights it was pretty
clear and he probably liked it if you
said his name I won't say his name he
might be in prison now and you don't
want to spread that rumor when something
good but
if he's in prison they found out this
took a dark turn to you and the guy with
the darker so we're doing two large eggs
things in the teacher weapon at the end
he said to you were very good with the
with the slapstick and you your
movements fantastic and you young man
you were wearing he was wearing a
codpiece and that was very popular at
the time and my friend went what I
wasn't wearing a codpiece and the
teacher went oh congratulations old boy
good job well done we have a clip here I
believe this we have a lion clip this is
this is right outside not for Dahmer you
actually got to this is the mime of
Nostradamus let's take let's take a look
at this clip from perception you you hey
hey hey here all day did you see anyone
fiddling around with the cobblestones on
the ground over there but this is a
police matter do you understand police
officially say import home did what
who's a reboot dr. Pierce who are you
talking to
[Applause]
[Music]
never mind I'm a French mind although
there's a happy ending when you realize
that a mime isn't really there you're
relieved oh thank god they're not
letting that just my broken brain better
to have a broken brain than see a real
mind I think it's a lesson there